eccovi qui
benvenuti in un nuovo video prima di
tutto mi presento io sono strega marina
la vostra strega preferita ovviamente
come avrete notato oggi parliamo di
halloween in particolare di
travestimenti l'anno scorso mia nipote
marina vi aveva proposto tre look tra i
travestimenti per halloween vi lascio il
video qui sopra se non l'avete ancora
visto andatelo a vedere quest'anno
strega marina vi insegnerà a
trasformarvi in alcune delle più temute
streghe della pista c'era una volta una
strega cattiva di nome malefica iniziamo
proprio da lei per prima cosa con una
spugnetta ho steso su tutto il viso
della pittura per viso bianca la trovate
tranquillamente nei negozi di
travestimenti dopo aver passato della
colla stick sulle sopracciglia
precedentemente pettinate verso l'alto
una volta asciugata locali o tempo nate
con della cifra fissante sono andata
quindi a disegnare le sopracciglia con
una pomata per sopracciglia cercando di
renderle più arcuate possibili da vera
strega cattiva insomma
per quanto riguarda gli occhi utilizzato
un ombretto viola che ho steso sulla
palpebra fissa sfumandolo verso quella
mobile o poi applicato sulla palpebra
mobile un ombretto lilla metallizzato
ed eccoci arrivati al momento del nostro
amato eyeliner che ho applicato sia
sulla rima ciliare superiore allungando
bene l'angolo esterno dell'occhio sia
sulla rima ciliare inferiore per rendere
ancora più intenso lo sguardo
ho applicato poi il correttore che ho
speso bene col beauty blender
il mascara
e per enfatizzare ulteriormente lo
sguardo delle ciglia finte
dopodiché sono passata al contouring
malefica aveva il viso molto scavato
perciò con un colore molto più scuro del
resto dell'incarnato sono andata a
sottolineare bene la zona degli zigomi
per metterli ancora più in risalto o
assottigliato anche il naso per renderlo
più affusolato
[Musica]
e ho applicato dell'illuminante sia
sulla punta del naso sia sopra gli
zigomi
[Musica]
sono passata infine a definire con una
matita rossa il contorno labbra
[Musica]
per poi applicare un rossetto rosso
super super matt e vuole
[Musica]
[Applauso]
per quanto riguarda la ospita utilizzato
un vestito nero vintage di mia mamma con
del cartoncino nero ho ricreato il collo
della vita di malefica un bel cinturone
in vita e ho comprato le corna di ma
l'etica online che fantastica
trasformazione una malefica davvero
malefica la dolce biancaneve non poteva
immaginare che quella povera vecchina
che le stava gentilmente offrendo una
mera in realtà era la regina cattiva
a questo punto non ci resta altro che
trasformarci nella povero vecchina che
disse biancaneve mangia questa mail
[Musica]
iniziamo stendendo un fondotinta molto
chiaro o un correttore in questo caso
utilizzato un correttore super coprente
e lo sentiamo bene su tutto il viso
comprese le sopracciglia
per quanto riguarda gli occhi applicate
un ombretto grigio sia sulla palpebra
fissa e mobile sia sotto l'occhio
creando l'effetto diciamo super occhiaia
con una matita marrone sono andata ad
accentuare ulteriormente questo effetto
e ho letteralmente cerchiato l'occhio
ho applicato poi un eyeliner bianco
sulla rima ciliare inferiore e superiore
mentre all'interno dell'occhio ho
applicato una matita bianca
[Musica]
ho poi iniziato a disegnare delle
arquati stime sopracciglia con una
matita per sopracciglia marrone scuro
a questo punto con una matita marrone
sono andata a disegnare tutte le rughe
per assottigliare il volto applicato un
fondotinta scuro ai lati del viso e sono
poi è andata ad accentuare l'effetto con
una terra ancora più scura con un
pennellino iniziato a sfumare tutte le
rughe create in precedenza con l'aiuto
anche di un ombretto marrone per
renderle più naturali e poi con liner
bianco sono andata a riempire i buchi
tra le rughe per creare l'effetto luce
ombra e quindi renderle più
tridimensionali
con la matita marrone mi sono fatta un
bel neo sulla guancia e poi con una
matita viola iniziato a disegnare il
contorno labbra cercando di allargare il
più possibile la bocca e lasciando un
piccolo spazietto vuoto adesso capirete
perché ho applicato un rossetto viola
scuro e sono andata a riempire lo spazio
vuoto con liner bianco ed ecco qui un
bellissimo dente fondamentale per questo
trucco e il naso da strega che ho
comprato in un negozio di travestimenti
dopo averlo tagliato per adattarlo al
meglio il mio viso lo incollato al mio
naso
premendo qualche secondo per farlo
aderire bene
[Musica]
per la ufita utilizzato un vestito di
velluto nero che avevo in casa ho
comprato un mantello sempre vi dell'urto
è ovviamente oltre al naso una bella
parrucca bianca non mangerò mai più una
mela spero che i travestimenti delle mie
colleghe vi siano piaciuti e chissà
magari potrete ispirarvi proprio a loro
per i vostri costumi di halloween ma i
travestimenti non sono finiti qui
infatti nel prossimo video vi aiuterò
trasformarvi in altre due mie colleghe
ancora più cattive ma critico cattive
cattivissime una in particolare è
proprio crudele
sto parlando non lo posso dire
beh mi dispiace dovrete aspettare il
video per scoprirlo se non lo avete
ancora fatto ricordatevi di iscrivervi
al mio canale e di cliccare sulla
campanella vicina al tasso d'iscrizione
per rimanere sempre aggiornati sui nuovi
video e per essere i primi a commentare
infine seguitemi su tutti gli altri
social in ster facebook e tic toc
per il momento ci dobbiamo salutare ma
ricordate questo non è un addio è un
arrivederci
[Musica]
a